hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong alongside the
great Jacqueline Coley I am merely Mark
Ellis and what a program we have for
y'all today with a very very special
guest so Jacqueline you know I don't do
the very very special guests too often
so this is going to be something and the
fact that you and I are still on
speaking terms means that my football
team hasn't played yours yet but that
will be happening this weekend it does
happen this weekend and I like put a
little in there because this past Sunday
after you cheated on our friendship with
the Bears and then Aaron Rodgers walked
into that house and just dominated
because he owns them and still owns them
certainly does it was a great day it was
a great day on Sunday I'm not gonna lie
it was like fitting look it's it it's
our modern sport but back in medieval
times jousting was all the rage and
that's why we are talking about the
movie A Knight's Tale it came out way
back in the summer of 2000 one 59
rotten oh so close I like to call it
fresh adjacent it is a fresh movie
Corner the audience scores 79 percent
and our guest today who are going to be
chewing the fat with all things and
night's tale is the one the only Mr Tim
Blake Nelson you know him from
everything from the recent battle Buster
Scruggs to Oh Brother Where Art Thou
which I believe was a year before A
Knight's Tale
um The Watchman TV show so many Coen
Brothers Works he's just a fantastic
actor who's been doing it a long time
and we're so blessed and happy to have
him on he's a writer as a playwright I
mean he really does it all in his new
film Old Henry which he stars in is
currently available on VOD it is a
really cool Western and there's a lot in
there there's more than meets the eye is
what I will say with old Henry and so
Jack we're talking about tonight's tale
today and I'm sure we'll get into a
bunch of other movies with Tim Blake
Nelson but as far as the Knight's Tale
goes why don't you refresh everybody's
memory as to to what the hell is it
about
yes so the Knight's Tale is a medieval
kind of uh romance adventure and it
stars Heath Ledger uh Shannon Salzman
Mark Addy Alan tudik Rufus Sowell and a
whole bunch of other folks also Paul
Bettany and it tells the story of a
group of Squires that is played by Alan
Heath Ledger and also Mark addy they
play those three and they their Knight
that they work for and they're sort of
his crew is a drunken idiot and he dies
in the middle of a tournament but the
tournaments the reason why these nice
competes in them is for the prize money
and so if sir Hector who's the guy dies
they are basically going to be destitute
so in an effort to make sure they can
get enough money to sort of you know
figure out what to do after this dude is
done Heath Ledger's character gets on to
the horse and
goes and impersonates his boss but he
takes the prize and that sort of sets
him on a path of impersonating a knight
even though he was born as a squire but
he's pretty good and in the course of
that he captures the attention of some
good people like uh Shannon salisbury's
character who is sort of a name
Shannon did I say Salisbury
hey Salisbury Shannon sauceman
thank you uh he sort of gets enamored
with her she's a lady and he knows very
well that she is not going to be able to
deal with him once she finds out his
real parentage and also very I would say
nefarious people like Ruth Rufus uh
Solo's character who again he always
plays a villain in every movie as we
already know poor guy but yeah so he
goes to the tournaments he starts
winning he starts losing he tries to woo
her the main thing that happens though
is one of the tournaments he competes
against the king of the Future King of
England played by James purfoy Prince
Edward and Prince Edward just wants to
joust like everyone else it's National
Pastime but nobody wants to injure the
king and Jousting is a very deadly sport
so everyone else in the tournament won't
fight him but
Keith legislature's character will fight
him
ends up that Keith Ledger and Rufus end
up in the final bit of the tournament
they're going up against each other he
loses because Rufus cheats because he's
always the bad guy and they also find
out that he is not a noble birth and
he's not a knight he ends up getting in
a lot trouble put in the pillory but
lo and behold the Future King of England
comes to save the day for him makes him
a knight and they get to walk off into
the sunset it's medieval jousting meets
a modern music score and it is A
Knight's Tale and for more on what the
critics were saying at the time of a
knight's Tales release way back oh my
God it's 20 years ago we were all so
young Tim Ryan our expert review
curation manager has his segment two
minutes with Tim
[Music]
and humans with 10 humans
[Music]
the critical knocks on A Knight's Tale
are as follows it's silly it's got a lot
of cliches it's too long it's uneven and
it's set in the Middle Ages while not
really being set in the Middle Ages but
for fans of A Knight's Tale many of
those things are actually virtues add to
that strong production values the use of
a classic Stadium Rock Anthem and a
performance that solidified Heath
Ledger's movie star status and you've
got a rousing goofy good time A Knight's
Tale is rotten at 59 with 151 reviews
but it does have a 79 audience score so
what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review Bob lingino of the Atlanta
Journal Constitution wrote those who
like Queen will find the love and honor
stuff boring while those looking for a
touch of Camelot magic will find the hip
stuff annoying and mood breaking however
in a fresh review Kimberly Jones of the
Austin Chronicle wrote minor grievances
aside this warped medieval yarn Glides
by on a funny friendly goofy sort of
goodness the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus reads once you get past
anachronisms A Knight's Tale becomes a
predictable if spirited Rocky on
Horseback so that's A Knight's Tale
let's kick it back to Jacqueline and
Mark they will they will rock you thank
you Tim and that just sets us up great
to go ahead and get into this interview
that we had with Mr Tim Blake Nelson
here we go and we are back with Tim
Blake Nelson welcome to Rotten Tomatoes
who's wrong Tim it's such a pleasure
having you on the show here and I did
get wind that you actually do have a lot
of feelings about the Tomato Meter and
that you were aware of the podcast and
so you you made a strong push to come on
here and obviously we love having you so
welcome to our world yes well thank you
very much and I um I have a movie called
anesthesia
that is
it is not even remotely close to being
fresh uh it's a movie I wrote and
directed uh and so um and I think it's
got a 24 or something on on Rotten
Tomatoes
uh so yes I have a special relationship
with the site although the movie I'm in
right now old Henry is is uh cranking in
at a 95 so it goes both ways I guess
he's doing great oh Lord he's doing
great and let's be honest you are mostly
on the Fresh side sir like I was looking
at you on the side I'm like there's not
too many that you uh that you're on the
other side on a bit and the great thing
about this show is we bring Justice
we've brought Justice to movies that
have a seven percent score and trust me
when I say that I I feel deeply it's
always about the snapshot I like that
well I was eager um to do my own movie
but I thought that would be incredibly
gauche so uh I opted for A Knight's Tale
well this is this will work as you're
like audition to be one of the crew here
one of our catch-up crew and then if if
you pass the audition then you can come
back and we'll talk about anesthesia and
we're gonna get that baby all the way up
to Fresh too so this is just the start
of a beautiful relationship and I'm glad
you brought up Old Henry right out of
the gate because it's available now on
VOD and Jack and I had a chance to check
it out and I I have some old Henry
questions I want to ask you particular
about how you develop that level of farm
strength and what that training entails
but before we get to that we also have a
movie that we're talking about where we
go even further back in history to
Medieval Times With A Knight's Tale and
as we mentioned at the top of the show A
Knight's Tale 59 rotten on the Tomato
Meter and it's just one of those films
like I mentioned Spaceballs is also 59
and it's just oh so close the good news
is that it's 79 with the audience score
so that's fresh there but I have a
feeling that we're talking about this
movie today Tim because you think Rotten
Tomatoes is indeed wrong about a night's
tale from 2001. I do uh and I think that
largely the movie was
either under appreciated for some for I
think it was underappreciated for the
chances it took
uh and or so sometimes both sometimes
just this that just that
um
and or
its Ambitions were missing
misinterpreted
um because the the movie is all about
anachronism
and its main conceit
is to mix in not only modern rock music
and you've got a score in there for a
medieval film which has uh Queen and War
and Thin Lizzy Clapton David Bowie
uh Bachmann Turner overdrive AC DC in a
medieval film
uh and this wasn't stuff that was pasted
on afterwards it was in the script and
in the way the movie is directed because
you have people actually
clapping to the queen song and moving to
the beat of this music there's a dance
number
um where uh they they dance to this
piece of music that Carter Burwell wrote
for medieval instruments that evolves
into a kind of funk piece and so the
conceits weren't slapped on afterwards
to save a movie they were always
intended to be part of the movie in a
really really
um smart and canny way
uh
they were used to promote the movie too
I mean I remember Jacqueline when this
was coming out I was I have a funny
backstory as to when I saw where I saw
this movie but I remember the big cell
was the Queen We Will Rock You and just
hearing that Primal
and yeah And the tagline of the movie
was he will rock you with a huge picture
of Heath ledgers at night so are you on
the same side as Tim here Jacqueline are
you saying that Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
is this score too low should it be a
fresh movie
I mean this movie should be fresh just
for Paul Bettany popping in being the
best like and out like the cast alone I
I really I can't talk enough about how I
felt that this film really hit what is
this like early 2000s yeah like very
early 2000s sort of sentiment and this
was I think my senior year of High
School freshman year of college uh 2001.
yeah I I love loved loved this movie
this movie was actually marketed to me
with Heath Ledger's face you know on
that poster I was the the core
demographic of that audience but anyone
else who came along was uh gonna have a
good time I I was in that boat too
because I the quick backstory and then
Tim I want to know where you were in
your life when you saw this movie
because I was still in college but I had
this this idea that was forming into
something where I wanted to be a
stand-up and I went to NYU during that
summer to take a couple writing like
comedic writing classes and very quickly
I realized I don't think I want to be
like a writer writer but I just want to
stand up and tell jokes I didn't know
how to do that yet and so I was just
kind of searching for myself in New York
for about a week and that billboard was
just the biggest billboard I've ever
seen for A Knight's Tale right there in
Times Square so I went to go see the
movie and it was just such a nice escape
and like Jacqueline said Heath Ledger's
face is selling her on the movie if you
incorporate rock music into a medieval
film that's all about jousting I'm gonna
wanna see it and I had a great time with
it I when we I found out this was the
topic of of our conversation I thought
yeah I mean it's a night 59 sounds right
watching the movie this past weekend
it's a lot of fun and it doesn't take
itself too seriously except for those
moments you're talking about where it's
clear that this was an intention of the
filmmaker from the start to incorporate
all these modern references and tunes
into a medieval story so where were you
where was Tim Blake Nelson in in his
acting career what were you what were
you were you on the scene yet were you
matriculating towards your dream in 2001
the summer of 2001.
well I didn't see it when it came out
um and matriculating into my dream I
mean I don't know where where I
that I got out of drama school in 1990
and and I did O Brother Where Art Thou
in 2000 and so I only really became
known as a film actor because of O
Brother Where Art Thou I've done The
Thin Red Line in 97 too but I was mostly
cut out of that but in terms of as you
say matriculating into my dream drink
into into my dreams uh I was doing
theater all through the 90s and I was
delighted to be doing that uh so I kind
of always had been
living the life I'd wanted to live I was
acting constantly just in theater
obscurely Off-Broadway in New York but
the reason that I initially saw this
movie was because I had
a seven-year-old son so this was in
about 1990 uh 2005.
uh and I watched it with him and I just
appreciated the
purity of its execution of what it
wanted to be
which was
um an overtly
anachronistic kind of revisionist
Knight's Tale
with
foregrounded references to Jeffrey
Chaucer including Paul Bettany actually
playing Chaucer in the movie
um that
was just for pure pleasure it was it was
as unpretentious a movie as I've ever
seen
and I think that's why the critics got
it wrong because they weren't willing
to take the movie on its own terms with
its
Ambitions and treat it as meaning to be
pure fun
because once you say this movie's
aspiration and it's a difficult one to
achieve is to be pure unadulterated fun
for its constituent audience
then you can't not but appreciate it
yeah let's get into some movie talk here
Jacqueline Let's uh Brian get cue the
music let's let's do this let's get deep
into this flick
[Music]
jacket let's start with you about what
your favorite scene your favorite scene
in a night's day like what's the one for
Jacqueline Coley that says oh yeah this
is why I love this movie not just that
Heath Ledger is the most beautiful
person on the planet when this film came
out I'm sure that's a selling point that
gets you into the theater what kept you
in there
um definitely and I've alluded to this I
love this movie I actually adored the
costumes of it I loved like the Grandeur
of it of course Heath Ledger is dreamy
we all knew that and an incredible actor
as well but really like I said Paul
betney's introduction when he comes in
it is one of the best character
introductions because it's like he just
comes to point out let's point out just
so we you know know where Jacqueline is
coming from that he appears in the movie
naked it does appear naked but it's not
just that he's naked it's just that he
is this bumbling
like a cantankerous writer but brilliant
and the way he speaks totally changes
the dialogue in that moment and it was
such the great juxtaposition of him
being like I am I'm brilliant beyond my
my peers but I'm also wandering around
here naked and I'm about to join this
ragtag group and I again it just it
totally you got the character in one
minute and of course Paul Bettany is
Just Born to play that that sort of like
Posh humor as I would like to say you
know like bringing in all of his like
British
um schooling in the in the like dramatic
arts to this just absolutely comedic
role and that's when I was like oh I
really understand this movie because
they were intentional with so much of it
with the cast that they made with it
because like when you look at the people
who are part of this this is not they're
not trying to make the CW's Night movie
they're actually trying to really
elevate it with the people they get
involved like Mark Addy
um Alan and Paul Bettany and of course
he let Heath Ledger like
Shannon I was just about to say and
Shannon they all really I think give
this thing the gravitas that gets lost
in the fact that you have people in the
bleachers stopping to We Will Rock You
which is really cool which is really
cool though I mean those jousting
sequences are so much fun but you know I
find myself going back to one of the
dance numbers that you were talking
about Tim where they're basically that
was when I'm in a theater and again I'm
maybe 20 years old and I'm watching it
and I'm thinking well what are we doing
here we're melding all this new I
probably didn't know what anachronistic
meant back then and I might still not
but you feel like
once that sequence takes place where
there's a dance scene where it's clear
that Shannon Sossaman and Heath Ledger's
character are having feelings for each
other and they're discovering it through
this interpretive dance of David Bowie's
Golden Years where you realize oh they
aren't just shoehorning a popular
soundtrack into this movie this was
actually written with the idea all along
to have these songs into this movie
because that's how they want to tell the
story yeah yeah that's that's absolutely
true and by the way let's not forget
Laura Fraser I was just about to say the
the girl like giving it like you will
not diss on my armor I loved her I was
like that's who I wanted to be in the
group yeah she's the blacksmith who's
making William his armor that uh suits
him a little bit better than uh than
possibly the competitors it is a great
cast if you had to point to one scene
Tim that you said okay that's why my son
and I enjoy the knights tell that that's
why this is a multi-generational crowd
pleaser what scene would you point to
there's a scene that's meant to be in I
believe Notre Dame
um between uh uh William Heath Ledger's
character and Jocelyn that played by
Shannon Sossaman uh and in the scene
she's going to challenge him to to lose
uh rather than win to prove his love uh
as a as a kind of um sacrifice or you
know a
um really Define the the truth of what
he's willing to give up for her because
she doesn't believe any night wins for a
woman a night wins for himself but if he
really wants to sacrifice for a woman
he'll lose for her because that's truly
a sacrifice
and we haven't mentioned the writer
director and producer of this movie
um Brian helgeland uh but he
um and uh uh Richard gratrix that the DP
have a tracking shot it's just a
parallel Dolly shot that's wide it looks
like it's probably a 35 millimeter lens
maybe even a 28. uh and it's just
tracking in a 50-52 shot between these
um two
leading you know the two ingenues of the
film and it's ultimately a very romantic
scene it's a it's a scene of courtship
and it's just such
a bold conceit uh and editorially and in
terms of the shooting strategy for a
mainstream movie you know the entire
team that came together for this this
movie with Tony Burroughs production
design is impeccable because it's never
overdone to where you think that the
anachronistic use of music is suddenly
not going to fit there's a sort of weird
cleanliness to the design that really
works and simplicity that that really
works
um uh Caroline Harris's costumes as
Jacqueline mentioned our Exquisite the
color palette of the movie is perfect
nothing ever pops out
um at you there's a real coherence to
that uh and the acting style as
Jacqueline was saying
it wasn't cast
with
CW actors no nothing against them they
they do a great job you actors end up
becoming wonderful actors later in life
but these are real actors I mean Rufus
Sewell that's what I was just about to
say Keith Mark Addy Alan Tudyk with whom
I've acted on stage and I feel like
Brian helgeland cast real actors in
these roles and you were talking I'll
shut up in a minute
um you were talking about
these people like we just know them from
IMDb talk more about your time with Alan
tooting real talk I love it so Paul
Bettany
Place Chaucer in this and there's an in
another movie He plays
um Darwin
because he's Darwin and Master and
Commander right uh and you know Paul
betney is just as you said he's an
Exquisite and exquisitely trained actor
and Alan Tudyk is as well funnily enough
I did a classic uh uh I did a play based
on Oedipus with with Alan Tudyk uh it's
Classic Stage Company in New York and
he's such a generous actor um with whom
to be on stage and you just get that in
the performance that Trio in um
in Knight's Tale of Heath Ledger and
Mark Addy and Alan Tudyk is is it's it's
like um uh it you know it's white like
watching great dancers work with one
another it's like a ballet they're
scenes yeah uh also I want to shout out
uh James perfoy another uh black prince
yeah yeah James perfoy who's you know
obviously a huge part of uh how that
movie plots there uh yeah no you you
kind of took the words out of my mouth
with with again just like the cast of
this it also to the director
um Brian the thing that I knew him from
which I think this may have been like
the first or second thing he did after
this was uh LA Confidential because he
was one of the screenwriters on that and
I'm like this guy is making specific
choices he's done a lot of really I
think incredible films that you know
like he doesn't mind taking big swings
and adapting James uh James's book which
is just this mess of like hundreds of
thousands of pages and condensing that
down he also did Mystic River the man I
think really understands stories and
swings and so yeah yeah and and let's
just take a further nod to Brian helgel
and the historical intelligence of
understanding what the Canterbury Tales
um is all about yeah are all about
entertainment
so the Canterbury Tales
the setting is
passing the time at night with
entertainment and people telling stories
to one another
and
it was absolutely a modern
thing of its time that piece of
literature
and so he takes
our
uh most thrilling and exciting
storytelling art form Cinema
and he updates a Canterbury Tale
to be the same sort of entertainment and
so it's tantamount in our modern culture
to what the Canterbury Tales were back
then and that's just so smart yeah it's
brilliant and I I can't let this
conversation continue because Jaclyn
said big swings and Allen said
historical context so I can't let this
go on without also mentioning Ryan
helgelin directed 42 the Jackie Robinson
Story Chadwick Boseman and that's got
big swings and it's got a lot of
historical value as well and if you this
I'm going to take a big swing with this
interview now because Tim I my favorite
character in this is actually Mark
Addy's character and it's funny because
Mark Addy would go on to be in that
medieval project that everyone just
takes so seriously I guess it's not
medieval it's in another land but it's
Game of Thrones and I think that there's
a chance that a lot of people when they
first reviewed A Knight's Tale were just
looking in this box of okay well if
you're medieval you got to be super
serious and you have to treat everything
as of the time time how we would a Game
of Thrones and judge it on those merits
But A Knight's Tale never wanted to be
that never cared about being that it was
like you said all about inspired by the
Canterbury Tales as a form of
entertainment is there a specific
character in here that that Tim Blake
Nelson says I would have loved a crack
at that character who would you have
played in A Knight's Tale if we can go
there
well I think the likelihood would have
been that I would have played uh either
um watt which is Alan tudick's character
or uh Roland which is Mark Addy's
character uh I wouldn't have been as
good as either of them so
I'm not you know I think that I I never
even knew this this uh movie existed
because it was uh I never auditioned for
it I you know it was before a Brother
Where Art Thou and so I wasn't on
anybody's map
um
but I guess the role I would want to
have played would have been adamir
adamar uh Rufus sewell's uh part and no
I wouldn't have been as good as Rufus uh
he was amazing uh but I would have liked
that role just because of the the I
don't know the challenges of it it would
have been outside my box uh
um it would have been much easier for me
to to slip into one of the other uh
roles uh Roland or what
um I don't wanna I don't want to steal
Mark's Thunder but I do have to say this
because it's just too good of a
transition that's kind of what I felt
watching Old Henry in this go in there
Jacqueline you were good thank you no
seriously though with old Henry because
what was great about that casting and I
don't want to give too much away but
they kind of allude to it in the trailer
is you're a man where not everybody
knows you possess a particular set of
skills maybe like you know what I mean
like you are a man that people are
underestimating and I loved your casting
in that because again this is not like
if you see a I don't know I'm like I'm
trying to think of like an actor right
now like if you saw Chris Pratt you know
chopping wood on a farm you're like yeah
dude that dude's about to go kill
somebody or you know what I mean like
but having you in this role I just loved
that turn and just how
like lethal you got in it and it was so
great to see the like don't look past
this person because you don't know
everybody's story and I loved that in
this and I'm wondering if that's what
attracted you to the role well it's in
part What attracted me to the role I
definitely I'm 57 now and I've been
doing this for a while and I want to be
challenged at the same time I don't want
to ruin somebody's movie and so
you know
I would never have been able to pull off
roof what Rufus Sewell did
in A Knight's Tale
even though that's the part I would want
to have played because it would have
been such a challenge and so had Brian
helgelin been inane enough to offer me
that role uh were I on his radar at the
time I probably would have said oh my
God thank you so much and you don't know
how difficult this is but don't cast me
I'm too small
I just I don't buy myself
on a horse uh jousting against Heath
Ledger and uh splintering a lance
against his armor it's just no people
will laugh at your movie and this script
is great and I love all the music and
everything you're intending it's
exciting but please
um Old Henry though
uh
was different because the actual
character I'm playing without giving it
away was actually physically
pretty much my
height and weight
and once I learned that
a lot of the dread I had about taking
the role on or enough of it dissipated
to where I said well I'm gonna go ahead
and try this that said I had to give it
a pretty serious thing
um because I'm I'm decidedly not in real
life
close to the character I play in that
movie
um I mean I kind of would hope not sorry
you seem like a you know all right guy
and again you have a contract with it
when when you take on a part with your
director
and that is I'm gonna come through for
you
and
um you know I take that contract very
very seriously
uh you know I'm not in drama school
anymore I played Falstaff
in my second year of drama school and
that's a role that nobody would ever
give me because he's meant to be
um
physically large and and and
um that was fine for drama school uh but
out in the professional world people
have a lot at stake in these projects
and you just you owe it to them
to do everything you can not to
disappoint and and that starts with
saying yes I think I can do this and
really believing that and not just being
your ego yeah you certainly didn't
disappoint in that movie because there
was a physical transformation that that
I noticed where you you seem to have I
mean it's weird to say it like this but
you you thickened up and there was like
Farm strength on you so what what sort
of what's that training regimen like
because you're also I I imagine working
on a lot of horsemanship skills at the
same time that you're you're trying to
look like you have been working on a
farm for decades
I luckily had about
um in part because of covet I had about
a year to prep for this movie now I was
doing other movies at the time so I I
wasn't solely concentrating on this but
I was certainly the the
matriculation onto the set was always on
the set was always on my radar and I was
working on it in some way shape or form
pretty much on a daily basis for about a
year and then in the I'd say month and a
half leading up to doing it uh
I was really concentrating on it and and
that involved both getting ready to play
the part physically and then actually
getting down to Tennessee where we Shot
the movie
um three weeks early uh to start you
know to learning to butcher a hog and
um uh working on the with the horses and
uh the I fire a lot of different guns in
the movie and really learning them so
well that they felt like they were
appendages rather than you know you need
to look like they're tools you use every
day obviously that's part of what an
actor has to do or gets to do I mean I
think it's a privilege to get to learn
all this stuff
um
and then the dialect and the look of the
guy and all of that we just took our
time uh the director and I
um and this wonderful uh makeup artist
with whom I've worked a lot named David
Atherton
um and so it was a
a good long process uh thankfully and it
is such a collaborative effort when when
you do really any movie but it's
circling back to A Knight's Tale a
little bit here I know Carter Burwell
you mentioned did did the score did
worked on the soundtrack with that and
burwell's also done a number of Coen
brothers
collabs I believe and so if we talk
about the music that is in a night's
tale is is what's the particular song
that you feel like was was most well
used what was the one it could be modern
we can just talk about what Carter did
On A Knight's Tale But how important was
the music and what's that one piece that
really stood out to you I think probably
the Bowie piece uh and the way it
interfaces with the period music
[Music]
um
you know there are two
levels of of the way that that Brian
helgelin uses the the rock music in the
movie one is
is sort of I'd call foregrounded
tongue-in-cheek
so when he uses a song like um taking
care of business the Bachmann Turner
overdrive classic or
um low rider uh by war or
um we Will Rock You the queen piece
early on he's he's winking at the
audience
and but then on a deeper level he uses
other songs and and I would I would say
that the Bowie piece is is this
uh that aren't as
um I don't know ironic would maybe be
the word uh or postmodern in in that
they're that they're commenting in a in
an almost humorous
way uh about what's going on on screen
and and and the anachronism is ironic
because it's so different from what it
is you're watching so it's the opposite
of it's It's kind of the opposite of its
meaning but the words are saying exactly
what the scene means and that aspect of
it isn't ironic
um
but that stuff's fun and great and works
but I'm more interested in the in in the
way that the Bowie song Works which is
actually quite
um
emotional and impactful and and and has
a real depth to it uh
and the the hair
um uh Shannon sossaman's hair in that
scene is amazing
um it's it's got this it's it's it's
it's dyed and it it has these sort of um
punk-like spikes uh and it's almost four
Shadows that you know you're gonna get
that song later that style of music
and so that would be probably be my
favorite yeah Jaclyn that one feels like
it is almost of the time in a weird way
and it's and it's the way that golden
years is utilized and I probably didn't
even know that that was a David bowieton
when I saw the movie but like I heard it
and I'm watching the scene play out I'm
in the theater I'm like that sounds like
Bowie and I'm trying to guess who this
is because I knew back when Turner
overdrive and I knew Queen but you also
just get into it that one just shuttles
you into the time period in a way that
some of the other ones did and although
I mean look a huge sports fan I love the
feeling of being in an arena or just
being at a joust with everybody doing
the we will rock you because it's just
you got to think you go back to the days
of of cavemen and they're making noises
like that to get themselves pumped up to
go you know hunt a saber-toothed tiger
yeah and I mean also I think the other
thing I wouldn't think is interesting is
Queen bookends it with We Are the
Champions and that was the one that more
hit for me it's like when we ride off
into and granite it's on the nose let's
be around like literally like he likes
that first level yeah you know what I
mean but it's still I thought was really
interesting and fun look I'm a huge
Queen fan you will be hard-pressed for
me to ever say there is a bad time to
listen to
um Freddie Mercury sing because that was
what he was put on this Earth to do but
if I wasn't gonna go for the obvious
choice I would take uh Sly and the
Family Stone I want to take you higher
because that is also as Mark knows you
don't know this Tim but I'm a huge fan
of the 70s I feel like in a lot of ways
I wish that that was more
um the sentiment and the music and the
style of now and so anytime I hear Sly
the Family Stone it just instantly
transports me to that time period so you
were born too late Jacqueline
like a radio version of a podcast and
just been ahead of our time for once we
would have been like the best radio Duo
on morning radio it would be an Austin
Texas or like where you were from in
North Carolina we'd be small Market but
we would be like beloved
you would be I've got to tell you
Jacqueline having lived through the 70s
uh as a I guess I was uh six when they
began
and 16 when 1980 came in uh there were
some that it wasn't all roses sure that
true that I like the look and the style
but let's be honest I'm not getting in a
time machine anytime soon that's always
the joke with black folks of like what
where would you want to go in history
nowhere
it's not good no this is like this is
not it gets really dicey anytime before
about 1980 and it's still dicey now so
no I don't want to go back in time
there's a great movie about a girl that
gets lost in the world of Jane Austen
and her best friend is played by a gugum
both of raw and she's like I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna go live in this time
frame come with me and she's like I'm
black no bye
yeah I just I just enjoy the modern the
modern medicines of the day that we do
that I don't think I need to go back any
further than that and that's why these
stuff you don't want to be bled when you
have a cold I mean seriously I don't
want any doctor acknowledging my humors
and saying which one we need to put
leeches on that doesn't sound like a
good day at my healthcare provider but
there's there's always things from every
decade that sort of bubble up and we say
oh well that's why I would let me be
there because that one specific thing
and I think that you know I I that is
one of the interesting things about a
night's tale is that it really doesn't
feel like a movie that necessarily came
out in 2001. look like you can't really
put this in a box as far as oh that
feels like an early 2000s movie it it
does have upon re-watching it 20 years
after it was released a Timeless quality
to it and and look one of the reasons
why we still celebrate this movie is the
guy who's on the poster who got you into
the theater and that's Heath Ledger and
so Heath Ledger had such a an Eclectic
career and has become an icon
is there is there something you can
point to Tim that you say that's why
Heath was just so so great but also so
so different and stood alone from other
actors of his generation
well I'm I um I met Heath uh
and I I think a lot of these guys
who break through and really
capture the cultural imagination in a
serious way
um have a decency about them
uh and and and that works on two levels
first of all they'll work again and
again because people want them around
and as a an actor who's been around for
a while and been around a lot of movie
stars it makes a difference when
a star is decent to others and Heath was
that he was just a good guy
he really was a good guy
uh and in spite of the fact that he
ended up acting irresponsibly and and
leaving us before he should have and
that included
uh his wonderful daughter whom I know
um actually better than I know Heath now
because I'm friends with Michelle
Williams
um he was a good dad
uh and
um at least as far as I saw uh
so but but also when someone is decent
the just the capture apparatus of a
movie camera whether it's digital or on
film
uh gives us more information about the
face and the person really that our eye
does
and
and even while it abstracts the human
face in a certain respect
it it
looks into you it gets you
um and I think Heath's decency as a
person
came through in his portrayals and I
include uh on a part like the Joker
um because this was an awful
uh
um uh
anarchic nihilistic
character
uh bent on destruction
but you never lost sight of that
character's pain
and somehow he humanized that song The
Joker yeah
um
Joaquin Phoenix did it too
yeah
and and and
and
and
so I think what I would say just again
as far as I knew he it was the decency
um and then there's the talent and the
fact that he was drop dead gorgeous
um and and a lot of other stuff and that
you know the talent was manifold
uh because he wasn't a movie star he was
an actor hmm
um which he proved in in Joker but also
Brokeback Mountain
uh
so um and and many other films uh
but yeah I would say
that in addition to the talent and the
incredible talent and good looks he was
a decent guy and that came through both
as in in his professional interactions
and his interactions you know through
the movie screen with audiences
yeah yeah and he is just so magnetic as
William in this movie where you just
root for him as soon as he's on screen
you just you just want the guy to get a
win and so there's no question there's
as when we see Rufus Soul pop up as Adam
are there's no way we're pulling for
this guy because he's going we want
Heath to be the the Underdog Story and
the movie sets him up like that and and
again just he he knocks it out of the
park and so having that sort of range as
an actor and and I would put you in that
class as well Tim it's just it's amazing
to see the variety of roles that one can
accomplish in their career is is this
the last time we see you in a western or
do we get more westerns now that old
Henry you're so great in it and you just
feel so authentic in it are we doing
more westerns are you done with westerns
after all that horse riding and farm
handing oh no I love westerns and
actually I'm I'm I'm supposed to I mean
they're they're developing it right now
um but there's a western supposed to do
perhaps next year that's based on The
Iliad oh excellent yeah oh I love that I
mean yeah that's out
this is the thing I think is interesting
about Greek
like
um poetry which was originally valid
like The Iliad it's the same thing as
like around the campfire stories for
like people that were going across the
trail like that whole idea of just
communal storytelling and to your point
the Canterbury Tales as well
um any sort of things that come out from
that those like Epic Journey type uh
stories I live for and again it was such
a joy to have to have you on the show
and the movie we're talking about that
you can currently catch Tim Blake Nelson
in is Old Henry it's available on VOD
wherever you are
um but we can't let you get out of here
though Tim before do you have a movie
recommendation that that you feel like
maybe can relate to A Knight's Tale in
some way or it's just something that
you're currently enjoying that you
checked out and you're like oh no the
world needs to know about this yeah I
can name a bunch of off the radar movies
that I've seen in the last year that I
love give me I'm just kidding
uh Give me liberty
one
uh evolution
I've seen that one is another
Under the Skin the load
which is a a
Croatian film is another so there are
some those are those are you know those
are obscure indie films that are nothing
short of extraordinary all of them I
will give it to you I cover independent
film and awards and I write a weekly
column and you got you got two movies on
that list I hadn't I hadn't uh hadn't
seen the load or heard of it and I
hadn't seen her Evolution and like just
let me tell you it'd be like trying to
get a sports uh stat pass Mark like you
were really deep on that one but I will
give you one better if you haven't seen
red rocket yet I saw that one and it is
my favorite movie of the year wow all
right I will see it and I would be
remiss though if I didn't just say that
it feels like you're going into the
Guillermo uh Toro universe and I am and
I mean really like getting deep
Pinocchio a nightmare alley you're also
doing this I think limited thing with
him but can you tell me anything about
nightmare alley as the awards editor I I
have to just like come on give it can
you give me anything
before you leave
I think it's one of the most Lucid
indictments of capitalism
that I've ever read wow
and
it soars poetically in that regard
and so what he did with
fascism in Devil's Backbone and in Pan's
Labyrinth
he does with
capitalism
in Nightmare alley and I want to raise
my hand and say I am a capitalist
uh I I I don't I don't have any you know
but but what Guillermo explores is the
is is the other side of it uh and it's
really ultimately an allegory to me uh
on capitalism oh Jaclyn you ask the
question now you you all done gone and
got me excited about this because I just
I just recently did an episode involving
Guillermo for my Show versus on peacock
and just researching and re-watching his
entire Library including the Devil's
Backbone which is just it's still so
mind-blowingly well done and it holds up
so well and it's so creepy but it also
has messages and Devil's Backbone is
definitely one you all should see too so
we gave everybody who's listening a lot
of homework and the not the least of
which is y'all gotta check out Tim Blake
Nelson's current film that might still
be in theaters but you can definitely
catch on bot uh VOD 2 is Old Henry it's
just a fantastic job as he did here
today as he always does the man delivers
whether he's on screen or on a podcast
uh Tim Blake Nelson it was an honor
having you on the show thank you for
being one of our more esteemed members
of our ketchup crew it was my absolute
pleasure
thank you so much fun having him on the
show I mean you're talking about one of
those great actors who you don't even
want to put in a box as just a character
actor especially after you see something
like Old Henry which again available on
VOD right now we don't have a mailbag
today so we're just going to remind you
all we always love your suggestions your
ideas your takes and you can email us
anytime RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and if you're
listening this right now I want you to
go ahead and leave a review a rating
something that helps us because you
enjoy the show and whatever podcast
platform you're currently enjoying us on
and for our very very special guest
today Tim Blake Nelson that is
Jacqueline Coley that is our engineer
Brian Perez producing Lucy in the
building I am Millie Mark else for all
the good folks here at Rotten Tomatoes
thank you for listening and we'll see
y'all next week for some snapping
[Music]
thank you